You've got to hand it to "The Mandalorian."
This possible plot hole has fans talking.
"The Mandalorian" Season 3 finale is here, and
boy, did the showrunners prove once again that
they know how to end a season. "The Return"
has all that any "Star Wars" fan could want:
Mandalorians doing aerial
combat with their jetpacks,
Din Djarin going full "John Wick," and
Grogu finally putting his Force training
to work. However, there's one casualty in
the episode that didn't make much sense.
The Darksaber has been a contentious
object throughout "The Mandalorian."
Whoever wielded the ancient weapon had the
right to rule Mandalore, so Moff Gideon and
Bo-Katan spent much of their time trying to
win it back. However, in the season finale,
Gideon does a complete 180, destroying the
legendary weapon in his fight against Bo-Katan.
"The Darksaber is gone."
While Gideon's motivations are confusing,
the bigger question is how he even crushed
the Darksaber with his hands. Not only does
he destroy it, but he does so with relative
ease while somehow leaving Bo-Katan's
hand seemingly intact. It's not enough
to ruin the finale, but it's a glaring
plot hole that needs more explanation.
"Star Wars" fans aren't exactly known
for their ability to let things go,
so "The Mandalorian" getting rid of a powerful
"Star Wars" weapon like the Darksaber has proven
to be a controversial move within the fandom. One
Reddit user commented after the episode aired,
"Kind of upset that the Darksaber got destroyed."
Other users had similarly strong opinions
on the fate of the legendary artifact,
with one fan calling it, quote, "the second
most emotional death of a non-character" in
the greater "Star Wars" canon. While
it seems that most fans agree that
the weapon's destruction was impactful,
the conversation quickly shifted to how
its demise ultimately made sense
within the "Star Wars" universe.
One user asked,
"How was Gideon able to
squash the hilt like that?"
Another viewer replied,
"I think his suit may have had
some mechanical improvements."
But another fan pointed out that the
beskar hilt should've withstood the
hydraulic-assisted fist. One fan also
pointed out that Moff Gideon should have
completely destroyed Bo-Katan's hand if he
had enough strength to crush the Darksaber.
Other users took a different approach,
suggesting that the death of the Darksaber
was for the best. One Reddit user admitted
they were happy to see it go, saying,
"Now the Mandos will just have to actually
pick the best leader in the future."
Another suggested that it plays into
Bo-Katan's character development, writing,
"[She] needed to realize she is still the
ruler of Mandalore even without the Darksaber."
Fans certainly have opinions on how the
Season 3 finale of "The Mandalorian"
dealt with the Darksaber, but there's
a slight chance that the weapon isn't
gone for good. From what fans know about
how lightsabers work, all variants of the
weapon are powered by a core kyber crystal. If
Gideon didn't crush the kyber crystal that the
Darksaber presumably contains within, then
its most vital component is still intact.
Some fans are even pretty confident that
the Darksaber will see a comeback in
Season 4 of "The Mandalorian" or
beyond. One fan wrote on Reddit,
"There's definitely a good
chance it will get remade,
yeah. The kyber crystal inside
is probably still fine."
Some even took the theory a step further,
with one fan suggesting it will be none
other than the newly-anointed Din Grogu
who reforges the Darksaber. After all,
the fresh Mandalorian apprentice
needs a fittingly powerful weapon.
Whatever the ultimate fate of the Darksaber is,
its ostensible destruction in "The Mandalorian's"
Season 3 finale will certainly have ripple
effects. It seems, at least for a time,
that the Mandalorians will have to learn
to live without the ancient weapon.